[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
I showed the garden is definitely
superficially like it's you know the 19
000 people yeah
and it's Madison Square Garden and Ali
fought Fraser there I saw you know AC DC
there when I was quite young and yeah
Led Zeppelin and I never saw there but
that's where they played that's where
the their concert film takes place yeah
that place touches a lot of you know
sure
uh it feels like a pinnacle in terms of
it's that many people it's New York City
it's the premier room that I got back
there and we sold it out I'm doing it in
the round I'm standing in the center and
so I want to just do that one night so I
can really appreciate it for what it is
because when I used to do it a lot it
was like I just take the subway into the
garden renting it is about 400 000
something like that yeah I forget to
just rent it of course it's astronomical
but they know they got you because you
want to play the guard you want to play
The Garden Louis CK has officially
announced in just 12 days from now he'll
be streaming live from the middle of
Madison Square Garden in New York City
as he performs a brand new hour of
stand-up comedy the Pay-Per-View event
titled Louis CK back to the garden
begins on Saturday January 28th at 7 30
PM Eastern and will be available to
re-watch for just three weeks after the
show after that it's gone forever
welcome back to the joke World comedy
update every single Monday bringing you
all the comedy news that you need to
know from your favorite comedians and
your favorite podcast anything happening
in the comedy world all on one YouTube
channel it's a sports center of Comedy
so if you want to stay in the loop make
sure to subscribe to joke world right
now follow on Instagram download this
episode on Apple or Spotify wherever you
listen to podcasts and leave a comment
for the algorithm you know how to help
the channel you know what to do you do
in the garden yes I am going back to the
Garden that's huge yes I'm really
excited I like that room it's you know
in terms of doing stand-up comedy is
that a room where you go this is the
Pinnacle
uh no I mean to me honestly any great
show is the Pinnacles so like I I've
done the garden eight times and my life
and uh it was important enough to
remember that it was eight I don't know
how many times I've been doing this it's
amazing Funny Bone I don't know how many
times but I can't say but
I've done the Columbus Funny Bone where
I've done shows where I'm looking out
the window of the plane the next day
going that was [ __ ] that was it that
was amazing that was it that's what I
worked for so Louis CK is set to return
to Madison Square Garden on January 28th
for one of the final stops on his
current Nationwide tour Lewis played the
garden many times in his career but
never quite like this this time it's
going to be streamed live off of his
website for the whole world to see as
part of one of the first ever
pay-per-view comedy events of its kind
I'm doing the Madison Square Garden at
the end of this month okay on January
20th and I'm live streaming that show on
my website and people will be able to
buy it there but buy a ticket yes
they'll be able to buy the show and
watch it for like 10 days then I'm
taking it down I just want to share that
night wow because I used to play The
Garden all the time I haven't been there
in years and I don't want to return that
to that I don't want to be an arena
comic I don't like the kind of pro
circuit thing anymore I just want to do
stand up because I love it but I got
back there and we sold it out I'm doing
it in the round I'm standing in the
center and so I want to just do it that
one night so I can really appreciate it
for what it is because when I used to do
it a lot it was like I just take the
subway into the garden
and I and there's a sadness that I
didn't see how great that was and now I
understand how great it was to have that
opportunity
so uh coming back there I'm calling that
special back to the garden and and so
folks can live stream and watch it
during the show wow and then I'll leave
it up for like 10 days just to stream
but then it'll come down and go away
although this will feel like a big
comedy event in January this live show
is technically not one of Louie's
specials he plans to keep the MSG stream
up on his website for about three weeks
after the show before it's pulled down
for good and his actual special is going
to drop sometime mid-February it's
already been recorded it'll be released
on his website for five dollars although
I'd still personally recommend tuning
into this live show because it seems
like it could be a while till we hear
from Louis CK again I mean I don't know
that's why the show at the Garden that
I'm doing
and I'm live streaming and it's all sold
yeah so the show I think we've got about
500 tickets left but it's like 19 000.
right but also you can buy you can you
can purchase it online and we'll put the
link in this video and we'll also make
sure that um we run an ad that week if
we don't if this doesn't come out that
week we'll run an ad that week for the
show oh thanks man yeah for sure it's
exciting but that to me is like a way to
like say a kind of a one more and
goodbye to that to that level
um uh and then I'm probably gonna take a
break for a while I think I might take a
year or more off and not perform for a
while I want to feel what life feels
like with that I haven't done that since
I was
18 I haven't stopped so your show is one
of the first shows I'd seen since the
maybe the first time that I'd seen
comedy that I went to and stood in line
and went to see com yeah wow that's yeah
that's that's rare I don't haven't done
that in a long time myself so McDonald's
the last guy I went bought a ticket and
sat and watched obviously Louis CK is a
comedy icon and people are gonna have
sky-high expectations going into any
Pay-Per-View event let alone one that
costs 25 which is definitely on the
pricier side but just based on what
other comedians who have seen him
Perform This Hour are saying about it
seems like it's going to be worth every
single penny for that live stream in
January January 28th is the special yeah
it's 25 bucks to watch it live or you
get to watch for 10 days and it's what I
saw last night yeah same show wow yeah
[ __ ] we might we might buy it I hope so
well you can have it for free no we'll
buy it okay we'll buy it man 35 days
after Louis CK goes live for Madison
Square Garden Chris Rock and Netflix are
teaming up to stream a live performance
of his latest special all around the
world starting on March 4th at 10 pm
Eastern I love Chris this is my favorite
growing up yeah he he astonished me when
he came back to stand up after SNL and
get inspired me a lot he was he's one of
the best friends I've ever had and uh he
was a great bot when he was just my boss
I just loved him he was the greatest
greatest guy he used to say like you
know I'm not it's not about me world
because he he hired writers that were
all really good and he said we're all
the Yankees I'm I'm in the I'm in the
cleanup spot but I'm just the guy who
has this one role but you're all you
know you've made us feel like we're all
part of it the vice president of stand
up at Netflix Robbie Pro which I didn't
know that was a real job that's a sweet
gig vice president of stand-up he said
quote Chris Rock is one of the most
iconic and important comedic voices of
Our Generation we're thrilled the entire
world will be able to experience the
live Chris Rock comedy event and be part
of Netflix history this will be an
unforgettable moment and we're so
honored that Chris is carrying this
torch we put out a video last week that
goes way more in depth on the live Chris
Rock special I definitely recommend go
watching that after you finish this
video but to start off 2023 two absolute
comedic Legends Chris Rock and Louis CK
both doing live specials or live
stand-up events makes me think it's not
going to be long until this is just
industry standard around all of Comedy
guest spots from last week your mom's
house had on Tom Papa two bears one cave
was Tom and Dr huberman kill Tony
tonight is Joe Rogan and Jesse Jet Ski
Johnston should be a good episode
flagrant did not have a guest Bill Burr
was on take her shoes off with Rick
Glassman and whiskey Ginger had on burnt
crystals let's have a little bit of sip
of something yeah you didn't drink last
night so you feel good I feel
fun I mean so crazy how good my whoop
recovery is 98 dude you're a whoop God
you guys are like whooped to the top I
love hoop and I'm paid to say it twice a
year like I'm paid to say so they pay
you to do it on the Pod uh we Todd Tom
and I do sponsored ads I think we have
to do twice a year at the very beginning
of October the very end of October uh
they are sponsors okay but I wear it
year round because you [ __ ] love it I
love it
um I I'm a ride or die for them because
it tells me how hard I mean I could do
read for them right now and I don't even
need to copy I don't even know what the
[ __ ] we don't even have a call to
action they're not they're not mine
they're not my spot but they're pretty
good they say the best one they say the
best best best thing you can get to um
deal with your sleep is the Apple watch
yeah someone else said that to me too
there's also the ring the the uh the UVA
ring your new nuva ring oh I think
nuva's the one that girls it knew was
this that's what I'm thinking of nuva is
the that'll help you sleep too though
this past weekend and theophon had on
Louis CK The Joe Rogan Experience with
Shane Gillis and the shaman Matt
mccuster we might be drunk talked with
Colin Quinn the Honeydew had on Drew
Lynch Sean Evans from hot ones was on
the Chrissy KS podcast and stavy's World
talked with Ali mccosafi as far as new
Sam specials go they're coming out
sooner have come out recently we've
actually already touched on the two
major ones in this video already Chris
Rock live streaming on Netflix starting
on March 4th at 10 pm and Louis CK
returns to the Garden on January 28th
Fall by his special coming out sometime
mid-February other than that let me know
in the comments what specials you guys
are watching which ones you're enjoying
that you'd like me to talk about in this
video and keep an eye out for Andrew
Santino cheeseburger comedy fans react
we're gonna do a video on that coming
out on Wednesday where we're taking your
comments your feedback from the special
putting in a nice video for them for you
to watch and like and just it's a
YouTube video I guess I don't have to
explain what a YouTube video is
sorry that does it for this episode
World comedy update as always thank you
so much for watching this video and
we'll be back again next Monday with
some more comedy news in the meantime
though we'll be posting some other
videos on this channel so make sure
you're subscribed Go download this audio
from Apple or Spotify wherever you
listen to podcasts if you want to help
out our show help out the joke World
brand make us you know climb those
charts maybe we can get some more guests
on here some more comedy interviews
that'd be great we're reaching out to
some people got some things in the works
I'm excited for the future of this
channel thank you so much for the
support leave a comment if you want to
help with this video get up there in the
algorithm leave a like
um that's it for me that's that's my
list of things that I wanted to ask you
for
let me know what you want from me okay
I'm always asking you to like and to
comment and to subscribe you tell me
some stuff to do it's it's a two-way
street here at joke World want to be as
accommodating as possible to the best
comedy fans in the world we're creating
a community of like-minded Comedy
individuals with the same senses of
humor people that just like cool funny
[ __ ] and that's you
and that's this channel I hope in your
eyes okay see you next Monday
actually no Wednesday with comedy fans
react to Cheeseburger Andrew Santino
cheeseburger Wednesday
that's it
[Music]